there's a less familiar story about
covid19
the crisis is boosting innovation with
the emergence of brand new ideas
mrna vaccine a new technology
and with the application of existing
ones in surprising new ways
the crisis has caused an acceleration in
adoption of technologies
this is pushing the world further into
the future
we've had to build more airplanes than
we ever have before
often at breakneck speed we just close
250 million pounds
businesses are being forced to adapt
hello oh thank you amazing or
face extinction another hammer blow to
britain's retail sector
this upsurge in innovation will bring
lasting change
for good and bad
could you get into your computer
this is my kid's future so what lessons
can be learned
as the world looks towards the
post-pandemic era
there is an opportunity for innovation
to stay at the cutting edge
[Applause]
[Music]
i haven't seen this is this a new piece
what is this part
the the front of the fuse got it this is
the headquarters of zipline
a drone manufacturing company this is 3d
printed
yeah oh this is plastic now yeah
oh yeah totally since the pandemic
the business has really taken off
drone technology has been around for a
while
but during the pandemic it's starting to
realize its considerable potential
with social distancing the new normal
health systems around the world are now
looking at drones
as a new and better way to deliver
products
such as blood cancer treatments and
vaccines
every hospital system and health system
on earth
is suddenly trying to reconfigure itself
to a new reality
to extend the reach of the hospital
system directly into the home
enabling care closer to where patients
live so they have to travel less it's
more convenient and the patient takes
less risk
of getting infected if they need to
access general care
from mid-june to september 2020
zipline delivered more than a hundred
thousand medical products
as many as over the previous three years
and we've done a few things the center
wing covers or no when did that change
ah weeks ago perhaps the most
significant change has come in countries
with strict
airspace laws in may 2020
an emergency license was issued in
america allowing zipline to fly
long-range delivery drones through
controlled airspace for the first time
and in december american regulators
issued new rules
allowing drones to fly over people and
at night
this looser approach is accelerating the
shift towards more states receiving
medical supplies
in a more efficient and productive way
so we're seeing hospital systems that
previously thought they had 10 years to
affect this kind of change
now trying to do this in one year
[Music]
although drone-filled skies are some way
off
kovid 19 has also accelerated the
conversation
around the use of drones beyond
healthcare
in a variety of new fields so i'll pop
this i'll pop this out
zipline has partnered with retail giant
walmart
it's one of a number of companies due to
begin trial deliveries of consumer
products
i think it's been really easy for people
to understand the value and there's a
pretty intense sense of civic pride
around
the country leading the way in terms of
showing how this new technology can save
lives
[Applause]
this kind of rapid adoption of emerging
technologies
has been called tech celebration
and it's the type of innovation that has
been given the biggest boost around the
world
by the pandemic a classic example is
tech acceleration
is what happened in the national health
service in england where a system to
make possible video calling
was effectively built over a weekend and
then rolled out to doctors across the
country
tech celebration is pushing companies
further
and faster into the future
exactly how many years into the future
we've been pushed by this crisis varies
it depends on the behavior it depends on
the country
but it does seem to be sort of off the
order of five years so welcome to 2025.
history shows that innovation often
thrives during times of crisis
[Music]
take the financial crash of 2008 which
led to the widespread adoption of cloud
computing
the cloud had been around since the
early 2000s
but it gained a new footing as the
economic slowdown took hold
companies were very often reluctant to
try cloud computing they thought it
wasn't secure
and then they gave it a try found it was
cheaper found it was more secure
and cloud computing has expanded very
rapidly
[Music]
as well as accelerating the adoption of
developing technologies
crises can also foster the development
of entirely new ideas
a good example of a crisis that led to
lots of invention would be the second
world war
so you get the first digital computers
which are used for code breaking
you get the first jet engines that paves
the way for mass
air travel you get nuclear technology
which is used for weapons but can also
be used to generate energy
and you also get the first rockets
[Music]
when it comes to new ideas covid19 has
left his mark in the field of medicine
where researchers around the world have
pioneered new techniques in the
development of vaccines
[Music]
this phenomenal work has been done
multiple teams producing vaccines in
months rather than years
using entirely new technologies in some
cases so these mlrna
vaccines are a new type of vaccine and
they seem to work extremely well
so that's very impressive example of
invention we are collectively telling
cafes pubs bars and restaurants
to close
[Music]
in most industries the pandemic has
boosted innovation by forcing companies
to adopt
new ways of doing things purely as a
matter of survival
we have innovated for necessity
even for michelin star restaurant owner
david moore
lockdown forced him to place 90 percent
of his staff on furlough
an emergency government scheme that pays
the wages of workers
for the business it meant we had no
income
i had thought that maybe we wouldn't be
able to get back
to doing what we did before
so to save his business david adopted
something once
unthinkable in the rarified world of
fine dining
a takeaway
the restaurant turned this
into this oh thank you amazing a heat at
home michelin star ready meal
[Music]
now the restaurant's vegan box has
proven so popular
it has been rolled out nationwide
i definitely see online as something
that is staying with us
it's totally invigorated the business
really that's the same fear
as businesses throughout the hospitality
industry have been forced to adapt
the pandemic has fueled the rapid growth
of the meal delivery industry
[Music]
globally the total revenue of this
industry
is now expected to reach 182 billion
dollars
by 2024 an increase of more than a third
from the projected level in 2020
when the pandemic recedes the innovative
mindset
many businesses have been forced to
embrace looks set to linger
for david the unexpected success of his
food delivery service
points to a hybrid model for the future
one that will allow his chefs to
continue to innovate
in the kitchen home delivery is not
going to finish
fine dining fine dining is here to stay
people want to be looked after
they want the crisp linen they want the
waiters looking after them
and they want no washing up afterwards
[Music]
but while the pandemic has made
innovation a necessity for some
companies
it has also restricted opportunities for
others
amidst the huge economic downturn
companies have been consolidating
the third quarter of 2020 was the
busiest for mergers and acquisitions in
three decades
a trend that is likely to tilt resources
for new thinking and new ideas
further towards big companies
by and large big companies can continue
to invest in difficult times they can
continue to take market share in a way
that small companies can't
and so generally this is leading to sort
of greater inequality between companies
it's a sort of big gets bigger
phenomenon
there are parts of america you can only
scout if you come in here
your international harvester dealers
showroom
history also suggests that successful
companies tend to start life more often
in the good times
than the bad of the biggest american
firms founded since 1970
more than 80 percent were born during
eras of growth
during economic downturns life can be
much harder for startups
which is so often the engines of
innovation
[Music]
but back in the booming world of online
food delivery
some startups have found hungry
investors
so we just closed um 250
million pounds sorry we just closed 250
million pounds
sisters ginny and eki newton run karma
kitchen
it's a startup that offers flexible
kitchen space
known as ghost kitchens to cooks and
restaurants catering mainly to the
delivery market
[Applause]
[Music]
while some ghost kitchens are owned by a
single restaurant
chain karma kitchen has many different
companies
hot stationing under one roof
producing everything from west african
donuts
to tandoori curries the company was
founded two years ago
and the pandemic has transformed its
fortunes
what would have taken us potentially
three years to achieve
has now taken eight months in terms of
market demand
the startup has recently opened its
second ghost kitchen in london
and it has another five sites under
construction
it plans to build many more ghost
kitchens in residential
and office hot spots across europe
we want to open 60 kitchen facilities
and
that starts for us with the funding the
ambition of fast growing startups like
karma kitchen
can attract investors but it can also
end with a startup
selling itself to a larger company with
deeper pockets
and that brings its own risks
you see from research on mergers and
acquisitions
when an acquisition happens the
innovativeness of that small fern
typically goes down the question really
is
whether large conglomerates will be able
to fuel these startups
in order for them to carry the front in
terms of innovation
and for that innovation to then be
disseminated into the rest of the
organization
for many large and small companies
working from home has been the most
significant innovation
to come out of the pandemic if you're
putting your energy into focusing on
your flaws
in 2020 covid19 turned a little-known
tech firm
into one of the success stories of the
pandemic
at the start of the year about 10
million people were taking part in
meetings over zoom
each day but this had shot up to 300
million
by april 2020 and the widespread
adoption of remote working during the
pandemic could lead to further
innovation in future
they will grow more companies
may be inclined to take risks and
embrace new ideas in the coming years
they've discovered that actually working
from home can work really well
doesn't seem to make people less
productive they make people more
productive that will mean that
after the crisis companies will be more
willing to keep some of those behaviors
maybe have less business travel maybe
have more working from home and maybe
even dare to try other things that they
were reluctant to so it's just
allowing them to be tested and not
punishing people if they don't work
because that's just going to put them
off
some of the most groundbreaking ideas
require the right opportunity and
circumstances
to demonstrate their value
two decades ago e-learning emerged as a
radical new idea
predicted to transform the world of
education
but such predictions fell flat
[Music]
sending all students home for the rest
of this semester after a coronavirus
outbreak on campus
until covid19 struck and the potential
of remote learning became clear
one of the questions that i had for you
is what you think it means to be healthy
the online education market is set to
nearly quadruple between 2019
and 2026.
the pandemic has really changed the
culture inside
educational institutions and made them
more open to
to adopting e-learning online learning
democratizes learning to a great extent
it
has allowed students to really customize
learning to to their needs
you could complete an entire degree
online because you may be in a
part of the world where it's very
difficult for you to commute to
to a university
[Music]
the culture change around online
learning seems here to stay
but with it comes a reminder that new
innovations
can also struggle to overcome some old
challenges
for full-time university student a
mum-of-three
christina holly studying before the
pandemic was going well
every semester i got a's and b's
i was meeting and beating my own
expectations
[Music]
and my kids were studying really hard
and grades were good
but now christina is unable to afford
the technology
required to allow her family to
participate in the switch to e-learning
having the transition to online
education was terrible
there weren't enough devices in the home
i want to try and restart the internet
first
using one chromebook for three children
is
terrible first of all their schedules
were
at the same time so when you have all
three of you have to start
school at 8 30 on one chromebook
it's impossible according to america's
education department
nearly one in eight children do not have
internet access via a desktop or laptop
at home
digital learning looks likely to
entrench social inequality
in the post-pandemic world
the reliance of technology has really
surfaced these
inequalities that existed before
but that were not as present because
everyone was in a room together
christina says that falling behind
could force her to become a part-time
student
and that this will reduce her financial
aid
and affect her ability to pay for her
college studies
i hate to even think about what that
means because this is my
my life you know this is my kids future
there is really no other option for me
other than school
this is what i need to do in order to
bring us out of poverty
[Music]
many of the innovations that have
flourished during the crisis
are centered around digital technology
and will have become
part of everyday life when the world
returns to more ordinary times
technologists and policymakers face the
challenge of ensuring these new
innovations do not entrench inequality
but instead broaden opportunity
i think that this is really an important
chance for humanity to not only bring
new technology to bear but for the first
time bring it to bear in a way that is
equitable for humans on earth
hello i'm tom standage deputy editor at
the economist
if you'd like to read more about how
covet 19 is driving
innovation then click on the link
opposite and if you'd like to watch more
of our now and next series then click on
the other link
thanks for watching and please don't
forget to subscribe